We
have newly released audio of Donald Trump
and the audio exposes.
Donald Trump, I guess, pretending during a
call with governors that he hadn't heard about
Corona virus testing being a problem.
Now, you know and I know that lack of testing
has been a problem for months now.
It's been a topic at almost every single White
House corona virus press briefing.
But Trump is, I guess, gaslighting governors
saying testing people can't get tests.
I haven't heard anything about that lately.
So this call took place Monday.
This was with governors from a number of the
different states and Montana governor, Democratic
governor in a red state, Steve Bullock explained,
we don't have tests.
And Trump says, I haven't heard about that
issue.
Testing.
Testing is a problem.
So let's go to the first clip.
You're going to hear Dr. Anthony Foushee in
the audio and you'll hear Governor Steve Bullock,
and then you're going to hear Trump.
So first, Fouche, she is explaining to Bullock
what you want to do is you want to test people
and then contact trace people.
And Bullock says contact tracing, we don't
even have we're almost out of tests here.
Take a listen.
Do you have any system in place that you feel
can adequately identify and isolate them and
contact tracing?
What are the capabilities going to be so severe
that that's not something that you could do,
given what you have done?
We're trying to do contact tracing, literally.
We are one day away.
We don't just hear from the CDC.
We have gone home in time to get to the private
side of the private market has been where
the private market is done.
It's natural resources that are then taken
out the first part.
Basically, we're getting our orders mask that
protects the supplies that potentially the
weapons.
So what we're trying to do on contact tracing.
We don't have to necessarily do.
We don't have an easy way.
And we're not finding the markets to be able
to do that.
So understand, Dr. Foushee is saying, you
know, what would be what you would want to
be doing is when people test positive.
You've got to isolate them and then you've
got to do contact tracing in Montana.
Figure out who they've been in touch with
and isolate those people.
This is how South Korea did it.
They had their first case essentially within
hours of the United States having its first
confirmed case.
And they dealt with the virus successfully.
Still not.
Not even 200 deaths total in South Korea.
And Governor Steve Bullock says contact tracing
were like a day or two from having no tests
at all and having no PPE left personal protective
equipment.
So now we continue with the same audio and
you'll hear Donald Trump jump in and say,
I haven't heard about testing being a problem
along the way of private suppliers.
We do have to rely on a national TV distribution
network.
And again, we aren't doing our best to try
to do exactly that in this downtown with the
example where we have almost half of our overall
state.
Those are the policies we're trying to shift
the supply to really laid made that contract
greatly, but we just don't have enough supplies.
Just tell me you can answer if you want, but
I haven't heard about testing in weeks.
We've tested more now than any nation in the
world.
We've got these great guests who would come
out with another one tomorrow where, you know,
it's almost instantaneous testing.
But I haven't heard about testing being about
that version of Trump that we see at the briefings
where he says, hey, we're testing more than
anybody else.
We've got the best tests.
That is apparently not a character that appears
to be the real Donald Trump that shows up
to the governors conference calls as well
and says testing.
I don't know about any problem with testing.
We have people waiting eight days for test
results.
And anecdotally, we have people waiting even
longer.
If and when they can get a test, which not
everybody can.
There are hundreds of people, thousands of
people who are recovering from the virus before
they even get their test results.
If you can believe it, because that's how
long it's taking.
Do you guys think that Trump is even thinking
about this stuff between press briefings like
I like to imagine.
Excuse me that a president is working all
day on this despite having, you know, an almost
totally clear schedule, which Donald Trump
has had.
But then he comes out with this testing.
I haven't heard about any kind of testing
issues for weeks.
And you have to wonder, is he just doing golf
simulator and eating his famous taco salads
all day and not thinking about this whatsoever?
He even talked about testing this week.
He was asked about testing this week by reporters
that led to the entire per cap.
You know, 38 million people live in Seoul,
South Korea.
Embarrassment, how can he say he hasn't heard
anything about testing for weeks?
A reporter asked him about it the same day
or the day before that this conference call
took place.
So the question as often is the question with
Donald Trump, is he merely ignorant?
Is he impaired?
And his memory is failing him?
Is he just lying to governors and gaslighting
them?
What do you think is going on here?
What do you believe?
Explains Trump, saying, I haven't heard anything
about testing for weeks now.